the world
she's the worst in the world john
ralphio how are you tommy t you just
missed the craziest of crazies clubs
girls dancing naked mom argument police
fleeing the seat hiding in a dumpster
coming here crashing on your couch for a
week cause technically i'm homeless hey
moustache i'm gonna hit the couch you
know i'll be
what up big cheese stop
this must be the lovely donna ashante
listen beautiful let's cut the ball
right you want this
i definitely want this t.h wants this
let's seal this devil's three-way right
here right now step one we buy into this
club step two we roll over to the club
either in your mercedes-benz or my
pre-owned acura legend step three i
dagger you on the dance floor just
bounce bounce bounce bad sounds now all
the ladies saying bounce bounce bounce
bounce bounce
what do you say sexy
i'm out why i hate that guy
hold up my dad said that yeah john
ralphio he told me
that i had screwed you out of my
business
so he was gonna screw me back any idea
why he'd believe such a thing that is so
weird
that is so oh you know what honestly not
i'm thinking about it this may be it i
actually told him that rent-a-swag was
my idea and that you had stole it from
me why would you say that because my dad
is always riding me for never having a
job and i just didn't want to show that
i blew it again
oh
and i don't know if this is relevant but
i told him that you made me sign up for
a bunch of credit cards and then max
them out by buying illegal white jaguar
fur coat oh
that's probably not relevant it's not
relevant though i don't know
all that's lying about me stops now
this is my life please one of you has to
tell him the truth got it oh you got me
oh okay fine you know what
i'm gonna do the unthinkable
i'm going to have a short honest
conversation with my father thank you
ha ha ha ha
he's running rafael that's me i didn't
realize you were a part of this of
course he is he's my business partner ah
clean
business partner now and forever hold up
forever 21 21 gun salute salute your
shorts caboose i just reassociated all
over the mustache that's just one of
many skills he brings to this business
partnership what are the shrimp ah
okay rethink that move son
oh my god yeah i know i know i know hey
john ralphio how's it going it's going
good i'm actually right here for an
appointment getting a brazilian by the
way there is a woman over there that is
unbelievable her name is kim when she
rips it off she smiles and it makes you
feel things throw my name i get a
referral discount if you don't mind okay
i heard somebody resigned in disgrace my
question to you is how you making that
paper oh yeah well i've interviewed
around uh but i'm actually about to take
a job doing in-house accounting for an
accounting firm
i almost fell asleep during that
sentence okay let me get this straight
you would be an accountant
for accountants
yeah so at this accounting firm you
would have the boring job
are you nuts this is probably the first
time you've had off since you've been
kid president true or false
true why don't you use that time and go
after one of your passions like model
trains or like toy gandalfs or something
oh why you jump straight to model trains
i mean
it's accurate i'm gonna tell you
something that i once heard from a very
very smart woman named kim
the lady who waxes you she told me if
you don't love what you do
then why do it
then she ripped the hair from my b-hole
welcome mr saperstein thank you so much
i will just show you to your cubicle i
can't i bet it's a big one huh barney
the uh temp agency said that you are
fluent with quickbooks pro correct all
right yeah we should cover that you see
my resume might not actually be accurate
right so i have no idea what you're
talking about don't know what quickbooks
are
you don't have any accounting experience
no no no barney come on but you don't
have to be an accountant to know that
this girl is a 10. yeah what up diaz you
come here often to my job ooh he's gonna
mouth on her also shut it is this the
new temp who's supposed to help me with
the spreadsheets i want to talk about
spreading in sheets when we go back to
my place and i will rock your you're
fired that makes sense so i just go out
the same way i came in
i can't figure out how to phrase this
mission statement let me get a shot at
it i'm actually pretty good at this
stuff
see
you just googled amanda bynes sideboob
what's wrong with you what's wrong with
you why is your safe search on that is
amateur hour tom listen
we've been at this for an entire evening
i say why don't we cut our losses if it
was such a good idea we would be
millionaires by now hello look man i
believe in this idea do you
you know i love you but
i don't think you're as serious about
this business as i am oh yeah no i'm
definitely not
and let me just say how truly
deeply true it is to be standing in this
dope-ass conference room and dressing a
group of people in a business meeting
it's really a dream come true uh right
now i want to turn the floor over to
jean ralphio who has something to say
tom
lawyer guy
daddy
tom did not screw me out of the company
he gave me every opportunity to jump in
at the ground floor and i said no not
because i thought it was a bad idea but
because and this is very important
i really didn't care about what was
happening so why exactly did you lie
when i asked you what had happened daddy
daddy well i lie to you all the time all
those math camps i said i went to i
don't even know what a math camp is
so all those postcards that you sent me
all those trophies that you'd won
trophies i bought
swan song
what up my man are you kidding me john
ralphio i thought you and tom were
working on your presentation no i
decided it was best if i took my talents
elsewhere do you know what i mean you
abandoned your friend god no he fired me
straight up talked about how i wasn't
serious enough about the project how he
needed to grow up anyway i have an
amazing investment idea for you condoms
with pictures on them good smart i think
you made my decision take care
how many times did you and i deliver a
form to maintenance just like this ugh
so many great conversations
bonding and mentoring moments it seems
only right that we make this journey one
final time
what was that boo-boo nothing ah
tommy t
and sexy lexi nope
what are you too bad larry's up to well
this is our last day in pawnee and we
have one last problem to fix hold up
you're leaving for truth
i am gonna miss you so much what's going
on you're not injured uh yeah i'm
injured i got a terminal case of it get
me to the front of the line in six flags
shout out
it's all winter wonderland
i'm gonna be so sad to see you go
because i finagled my way onto your
family phone plan and when you leave
that all goes away from me generous hush
child for one second
will you do me one
final kindness
will you
pretend to be my wife for an insurance
scam but then we fall in love for real
also can i have a pair of your gym socks
and dory it's not for anything weird
it's just a fetish i have
john ralphio yeah although i truly hope
that i never see you again
i do wish you
a long and happy life
today we say goodbye to jean-ralphio
saperstein
as per his last will and testament we
will now listen to his favorite song
bend over by lil jon featuring tyga
we're making me take your airboat
[Music]
okay okay they bought it they bought it
do you have the insurance money no job
no doubt let's hit it bro time to start
a casino in a tajikistan
talk
oh don't worry about daddy stan
this is the best idea you've ever had no
no this is god's idea i'm just the best
man
you sneak out of here do not be
suspicious
god
you